ja man jetzt zu ihrem Husarenstück wann
und warum haben Sie sich zu dieser 33
Seiten hatte diese Klage vor dem
Verfassungsgericht sind ja selber
Volljurist aber sie ist selber ich hatte
zwei Mitarbeiter in meinem Büro eines
Jura Student eigentlich sehr begabt und
der andere ist ein junger
wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter auch
guter Jurist wir haben schon sehr
geholfen aber geschrieben und auch die
Idee entwickelt was ist eigentlich der
Antrag und warum dann
was war der Gedanke was hat sie dazu
gemacht was war der Auslöser erst also
mir fällt schon seit langem auch in der
merkelzeit habe ich auch öffentlich
gemacht mit einer weniger
ein Buch darüber geschrieben
neue Gesetze für die Gesetze
fällt dass der Bundestag immer kürzer
über die Dinge bereden und dabei
entstehen sehr viele handwerkliche
Fehler da gibt's gar nicht um die Frage
jetzt Gasheizung oder es geht um die
Frage wie sind ja nicht handwerklich und
diese handwerklichen Fehler führen ja
bei den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern und bei
den Unternehmen dazu dass sie Anwälte
Fragen und sagen was heißt denn das
jetzt eigentlich genau und jeder
Bürokratie ich glaube auch dass alle
meine Kollegen im Deutschen Bundestag
gerne weniger Bürokratie hätten aber wir
schaffen mit diesen handwerklichen
Fehlern ganz viel Bürokratie und das
stört mich seit langem und jetzt hat die
Ampel das Problem verschärft
ich habe ihn heute vom
wissenschaftlichen Dienst eine
Ausführung bekommen dass die
Durchschnittszahl der Beratungstage in
der Ampelphase um 35% noch mal
zurückgegangen sind über alle Gesetze
also die Tage die das im Bundestag liegt
im Drittel weniger Drittel weniger
und dann habe ich mich wahnsinnig
geärgert über die EU notfallverordnung
deswegen ist jetzt für die Zuschauer
wahrscheinlich als ein Gesetz jedenfalls
dass sie unverschämter Weise durch
Parlament gebracht haben
und dann habe ich damals schon überlegt
ob ich klage ich bin auch relativ sicher
ich hätte das gewonnen aber ich hätte
die EU notfallverordnung damit insgesamt
zu Fall gebracht das fand ich
unverantwortlichen im Sinne des
Klimaschutzes deswegen habe ich nicht
gemacht
okay dann das habe ich aber gesagt dass
jetzt habe ich Robert Habeck gesagt das
habe ich den Fraktionsvorsitzenden aller
drei ampelparteien gesagt ist nicht so
dass die da vom Stuhl gefallen sind also
das geht so nicht und
ich bin ja schon gehört worden aber
passiert ist nichts dann hat Frau Bars
diesen Brief geschrieben also die
Parlamentspräsidentin und dann lief das
ja mit dem heizungsgesetz das ging ja
sehr streitig zu das ist ja auch hier
schon mehrfach behandelt was muss ich ja
nicht wiederholen und dann war immer
klarer dass sozusagen der eigentliche
Beratungszeit der Schrumpf für sozusagen
täglich zusammen und dann habe ich
gesagt das ist doch jetzt eine Idee weil
ich jetzt nicht weniger Klimaschutz
mache aber ich sozusagen den Bundestag
einfach mehr Beratungszeit erkämpfe und
das war mein Ziel habe ich ja auch
erreicht und ähm also ich fand den
Auftritt von Robert habe bei ihm
ziemlich überzeugend
insgesamt aber das mit dem Lesen was sie
auch eingangs erwähnt haben ich hatte es
natürlich vorher gelesen
ist der also das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat
Beratungszeit angeordnet nicht einen
neuen Notartermin und deswegen
Beratungszeit heißt man berät über die
Sache genau dazu ist die Ampel
offensichtlich noch nicht bereit was ich
für einen erneuten Verfassungsverstoß
halte das heißt sie würden noch mal
klang das so weit bin ich noch lange
nicht aber sie denken darüber nach nein
ich denke darüber nach der
Bundestagspräsidentin im Brief zu
schreiben
die haben ja noch die Chance das richtig
zu machen das muss man auch abwarten und
ich hoffe auch dass Sie es richtig
machen gesagt da gehen wir nicht mehr
ran das lassen wir so das haben sie
gesagt Kevin die eine Missachtung des
Beschlusses des Bundesverfassungsgericht
die nicht eine gesagt haben es muss noch
mal
einen neuen Termin geben sondern sie
haben gesagt es muss Beratung
und Beratung ist wenn man eine Sache
berät und nicht wenn man eine Sache
einfach mit aber das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat gesagt das
muss noch mal beraten werden
das heißt aber noch lange nicht dass es
deswegen geändert werden muss
beraten werden und wir von der Union und
auch ich persönlich
werden dazu eine ganze Reihe wir
arbeiten gerade daran das ist sehr viel
Material im bürostand gerade wo wir die
Ampel Fragen werden wie meint die
eigentlich das und warum ist dieses
mal ein Beispiel sagen viele Beispiele
sagen also leicht zu erklärendes
Beispiel ist wir haben Quartiere im
energierechtstrom und jetzt haben wir
für die nahwärmesysteme eine völlig neue
Regel was ist ein Quartier die Frage ist
warum ist es eigentlich anders als
Vermieter Strom da werden Doktorarbeiten
drüber geschrieben wenn wir das so
lassen warum ist das eingesetzt so
geschrieben
warum ist diese handwerklichen Dinge
handwerklichen Dinge
zu der Frage wie gehen wir eigentlich
mit Kraft wärmekopplung um wie gehen wir
mit mit Rest Gasheizung um die als
Spitzen also ich mache 65% Erneuerbaren
aber ich lasse meine ganze Gastherme -
15 Grad ist und Strom knapp ist dann
stehe ich sie noch mal für zwei Tage an
was ist denn dann eigentlich was ist mit
den Förderung der ist ganz viel unklar
also da gibt es also ich könnte die
ganze Sendung Ihnen hier voll erzählen
mit Dingen die mir nicht klar sind gut
und ich finde ich bin doch gewählt
worden um sowas zu klären für die
BürgerInnen
aber ist das nicht bitter wenn sie dann
sie beraten das jetzt alles sie gehen da
mit ganz große Ernsthaftigkeit dran wie
ich gerade merke kriegen sie schon dazu
dass Du daran
[Gelächter]
nicht ändern
Entscheidung aber wir werden das
thematisieren
gemacht wir haben auch alle gesagt dass
sie das am 2.3 Lesung in Form juli zu
machen ich glaube
das wird politisch total schwer
durchzuhalten von der Ampel das ist doch
so eine wie so eine trotz Reaktion ne
also so das Gericht zwingt uns zu
Beratung und dann ändern wir aber nichts
also wir tun nur so als ob wir beraten
ich glaube dass damit kommen die nicht
durch weil ähm es gibt auch dieses das
nennen Politiker immer das struktische
Gesetz nach dem früheren SPD kein Gesetz
kommt in Bundestag rein und geht genauso
wieder raus und deshalb Scholz und Mütze
nicht und alle Sozialdemokraten 100.000
Mal öffentlich gesagt und jetzt zu sagen
bei diesem wichtigen Gesetz ist es aber
nicht so da wird nichts mehr das kann
man nicht durchhalten
also diese ganze Eile ist ja auch
überhaupt nur entstanden weil die Ampel
Angst hat wenn wir noch mal drüber reden
fliegt es uns wieder auseinander weil
wir ja nicht einer Meinung sind so in
Wirklichkeit sind sie nicht einer
Meinung wir haben jetzt ein politisches
Formel Kompromiss und der soll jetzt
durchgeprügelt werden damit das Thema
weggeht weil das Thema der Abend genau
es gibt einen politischen Grund und ich
glaube jetzt diese Bilder für seine
Landtagswahl im Herbst nicht immer
weiter Futter liefern
zum Beispiel Schlagzeilen immer weitere
Diskussionen darüber Streit ja und die
x-anläufe gebraucht bis die diesen
Kompromiss hatten und die fragen sich ob
sie noch mal ein hinkriegen und das ist
natürlich aus ampelsicht verständlich
aber kann kein Grund sein gegen diese
Verfahren zu verstoßen und wie fanden
sie in dem Zusammenhang den Auftritt von
Robert habe sehr interessant dass sie
sagen das ist wirklich selten ich meine
sie sind nicht die Partei sondern das
ist ja der Hauptgegner in der Koalition
sind ja die Grünen und sie setzen sich
jetzt hier hin und sagen soll ich mal
sagen was er da gemacht hat fand ich gut
überwiegend
es geht jetzt nicht mehr
wegnehmen trotzdem sagt er Frage an
Robin Alexander das ist
ich finde aber
ein Politiker erstaunlich selbstkritisch
und das hat mir gefallen weil er ja
gesagt hat wir haben gedacht wir sind
noch im hoch hoch in der Hochphase des
der Energiekrise und dann können wir das
einfach so durchziehen und das also ich
finde sie haben es ganz falsch
angefangen es gibt noch mehr Fehler die
jetzt vielleicht auch selber nicht so
sieht wie ich aber
ich finde mit Selbstkritik fängt man
eigentlich an und das hat mir gefallen
das bricht einem auch keinen Zacken aus
der Krone wenn man das dann irgendwann
mal sagt ja ja ist aber sagt er trotzdem
es kann Beinbruch das wird uns nicht
weiter tangieren und dann so mit dieser
sehr lässigen so viel Samstag gut wenn
die noch eine Woche brauchen um das
besser zu verstehen dann kriegen sie
halt noch eine Woche gut
ja ich glaube das war nicht so clever
das zu sagen weil
ja weil also ich glaube erstmal dass das
politisch schwer durchzuhalten will und
dann ist es ja auch wirklich keine
kleine Sache also es ist ja jetzt nicht
ein politisches Spiel sondern da
passiert gerade in Sachen also wenn wenn
das nicht klappt mit diesem
heizungsgesetz wie auch immer hat man
den Klimaschutz in Deutschland echt ein
Schlag versetzt ja das muss man so
hatten keine kleine Sache so und deshalb
das ist schon passiert ich sollte habe
ich da auch ähm
hat der wirklich Grund zur Selbstkritik
was ich in dem Gespräch erstaunlich fand
dass er sich hier hinsetzt und sagt das
erste Gesetz war radikal
also die alte gleichen Fassung die er ja
eingebracht hat das ist ja auch noch
dieses ich hoffe ich langweile die
Zuschauer damit nicht aber mit den
Details aber das ist ja eigentlich ein
neues Gesetz im in dem Gefäß des alten
ja das ist eigentlich unseriös wenn man
ehrlich ist weil dieses alte Gesetz
haben die komplett neu gestrickt die
Grünen geben es nicht zu aber FDP und
SPD sagen offen es ist was neues und
damit müsste man eigentlich auch noch
mal neu anfangen und neu die Experten
daran holen und das ist ja auch so
Beratung ist nicht nur die Abgeordneten
sondern da kommen Experten die sich
ausgehen und sagen guck mal Leute das
habt Ihr vielleicht gut gemeint aber
wenn ihr das so drin lassen also das hat
schon Sinn das in Ruhe zu beraten
deshalb glaube ich alle habe ich
Begeisterung ihrerseits er hatte auch
Grund für Selbstkritik ich bin
trotzdem bemerkenswert dass das macht
wir sind hier oben die ganze Zeit habe
und sie wundern sich das nicht sie
sondern CDU generell
[Gelächter]
wir sind über über einen anderen Begriff
gestolpert vielleicht kann die Regie das
einmal kurz Zuschnitten ganz
interessantes Wort in diesem Gespräch
und da hatte ich das Gefühl weil sie
gerade den Staatssekretär Patrick reicht
noch mal erwähnt haben da kommt so
dieses sehr die registrische von oben
nach unten einfach mal Ansagen bis in
den letzten Heizungskeller hinein da kam
das vor wir hören mal kurz rein
Scheine Punkt ist das habe ich an
anderer Stelle auch gesagt dass dieses
Gesetz zwei Gründe hatte der erste war
Klimaschutz und der zweite Grund für die
Gaskrise die im letzten jahrtrote das
hat dazu geführt dass wir das Gesetz
vorgezogen haben wir haben uns ja auch
was zugemutet und sehr viele Unternehmen
hat ein sehr konkrete Angst das ist eine
gastmangelage gibt dass sie abgeschaltet
werden das war alles real deswegen es
ist eingestanden ist das ist das Gesetz
sehr schnell und auch in dem Sinne
radikal gewesen und gesagt dann haben
wir damit jetzt auch aus dieser ja ja
das ist sehr unstrittig radikal genau
das ist ein gutes Wort dafür ja das ist
aber auch das ist so das ist zuzugeben
aus dem was hätte passieren können in 22
Winter 23
angemessen ich habe ja gerade aufgezählt
was ich gesagt habe jedenfalls schien es
mir angemessen
radikal
ich fand bei dem Argument schwierig er
sagt ja damals mussten wir so schnell
wie möglich runter vom russengas und
deshalb dachten wir wenn wir alle
Gasheizungen sozusagen verbieten dann
das ist ein Beitrag dass wir vom gar
nicht runterkommen
wenn man bedenkt dass auch unser
Kohleausstieg immer noch einplant neue
Gaskraftwerke zu bauen unter anderem in
der schwarz-grünen Regierung von NRW die
haben glaube ich 9 neue Gaskraftwerke
geplant um den Kohleausstieg vorzuziehen
Klammer auf auch weil man keine AKWs
mehr laufen haben will wenn man das
alles bedenkt glaube ich
klingt das Argument besser als es in der
Substanz ist radikal
wer hat sie am Ende dazu bewogen diese
Verfassungsklage anzustreben also
wirklich auslösende Moment weil die
Antwort des ftp-fraktionsvorsitzenden du
auf meine wirklich ganz sachliche Frage
wie viel Seiten kommen da eigentlich und
wann kommen sie eigentlich sie stellen
diese simple Frage genau und dann
passiert folgendes wir hören mal kurz
rein wann dürfen wir denn mal mit Texten
rechnen wann kriegen wir denn die
Formulierungsvorschläge eines ja dann in
der Substanz völlig neuen Gesetzen wir
machen es uns eben nicht leicht wir
haben ja
das ist nein ja man könnte ja das ja
spannend man könnte ja so machen man
könnte es ja so machen wie ihre
Parteifreundin Ursula von der Leyen man
könnte ja genauso machen indem man
nämlich am Parlament vorbei am Parlament
vorbei und möglicherweise an die
Mitgliedstaaten vorbei absurde Dinge
forciert was ist der Vorschlag ihrer
Parteifreundin ihre Parteifreundin sagt
echte Klimaneutralität ist egal wir
setzen bürokratisch an der Anlage an
jeder Heizung in Europa muss in Zukunft
115% schaffen das ist gerade zu absurd
was sie da technisch fordern bitte
beziehen Sie Ihre Parteifreundin brüssel
den richtigen Kurs nämlich den Kurs
dieser Koalition einzuschlagen das muss
doch das Ziel sein uns in Deutschland
ist nichts geholfen wenn wir das hier
geschafft haben mit der Mehrheit aber
die Europäische Kommission und an der
Spitze ihre Parteifreundin all das
kombiniert das darf nicht passieren
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam arbeiten und
ursula von der Leuten überzeugen ich
danke Ihnen herzlich
[Applaus]
alles was sie jetzt sagen werden wir
morgen gegen ihn verwenden was haben sie
gesagt als das kam also Sie haben es ja
zusammengeschnitten das war ja jetzt
schon lang ja genau
sie war in der Sache übrigens falsch
die Vorwürfe gegen Frau von der Leyen
stimmen
kann aber ich hatte ja eine Frage
gestellt haben sie ja dargestellt und
ich hatte sie vorhin sachlich genannt
ich glaube der Zuschauer kann nach dem
wusste nicht dass ich vorführen und ich
kriege so eine Antwort da wie gesagt das
ist das ist eine derartige Arroganz der
Macht das lass ich mir nicht gefallen
wie weit die Ampel es mit diesem Gesetz
getrieben hat das ist ein
Fraktionsführer der Ampel und der wirft
jetzt der
CDU-Politikerin in Brüssel vor ein
klimapolitisch zu ambitionierte Vorhaben
zu machen das über das hinausgeht was
die Ampel in Deutschland macht also sie
haben
angefangen also habe gesagt selbst
radikal und jetzt sind sie so weit wir
lassen uns doch nicht von Brüssel zum
Klimaschutz zwingen
Frauen
für die Zuschauer was da in Brüssel
gerade
ist total interessant erregt sich auch
in der Sache völlig zu Unrecht auf ne ja
und zwar folgendes haben in Brüssel
machen worauf er anspielt mit den 15%
ist die Frage welche Auflagen nur die
Hersteller kriegen genau dass die
sogenannte ökodesignrichtlinie die
sozusagen da wird jeder Toaster muss
eine bestimmte Energieeffizienz haben
und das da ist die Frage welche
Energieeffizienz müssen Wärmepumpen
haben und da wollen die 115 Prozent 2029
vorschreiben das hat mit dem Bürger
erstmal hier gar nichts zu tun dass sie
die Frage was er wenn das kommt das ist
doch gar nicht entschieden und die
Bundesregierung hat ja viel mitzureden
im Gegensatz zu mir also ich
Oppositionspolitik hat da gar nicht mehr
gesehen aber
es geht darum was müssen Hersteller von
werbepunkten für die Energieeffizienz
und die können 115%. die können
wahrscheinlich sogar 300 sagen das ist
gar keine große Sache genau ja das ist
eine so polemische Antwort gewesen die
einfach gar nichts mit der Sache zu tun
hat und auf meine wie ich finde sehr
berechtigte Frage wann kann ich ja mal
anfangen zu arbeiten so eine Antwort zu
geben
ehrlich gesagt und es gibt noch es gibt
einen Vorläufer dazu Frau Konrad seine
Stellvertreterin die habe ich das auch
paar Tage vorher gefragt wann kommt denn
das der sagt doch Frau Konrad ich
arbeite doch nicht im bmwk deswegen kann
ich doch sowas nicht wissen die Frage
halte ich mich für
Wirtschaftsministerium sie arbeite nicht
Wirtschaft
die sagen doch die ganze Zeit dass ein
parlamentsaktivität ist die zuständige
stellvertretende Vorsitzende bei der FDP
und die dieser gibt mir die Antwort sie
würde nicht in Wirtschaftsministerium
arbeiten was ich weiß was sie ist ja
stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitzende
Feier auch schon ziemlich frech aber
gesagt Heilmann dann Erfolg hat da hat
er niemand lauter gejubelt als die FDP
also kubiki und Schäffler haben ja also
FDP da gar nicht super dieser grüne Plan
ist gestorben bestraft worden aber da
wir jetzt schon so ausführlich schlecht
über die Ampel gesprochen haben sollten
wir auch noch mal schlecht über die
Union sprechen
wie entschlossen seine eigene Fraktion
seine komische Klage beim
Verfassungsgericht unterstützt hat
richtig wenn ich einen Vorschlag Einrede
unterstellt dass die Kollegen nicht mit
mir gehofft hätten sie waren rechtlich
skeptischer als ich das ist die Wahrheit
aber sie wissen ja fünf Juristen sieben
Meinungen also da gingen die Meinung
auch in unserer Fraktion weit
auseinander aber erstens waren alle und
zwar sehr rechtzeitig informiert die
wussten schon dass ich das überlege und
dann habe ich ihn nach dem dirty Tat
gesagt jetzt reicht's mir ich mache es
und Friedrich Merz hat gesagt dann ist
dein Recht macht viel los und dann haben
sie vor allen Dingen 10 sehr
substanzielle Seiten anders
Verfassungsgericht geschrieben und meine
Argumentation mit weiteren Argumenten
unterstützt und so dann kann man jetzt
nicht sagen sie haben mir nicht geholfen
okay Schmerzen nicht und das ist einfach
also ich verstehe das ja sie sind doch
jetzt Teams haben wir doch sagen Sie das
sagen sie ja mit dem Unterton ich sage
die märz und nicht die Wüste und ich
möchte eigentlich Team CDU sein ja aber
aktuell sind sie eher Teams
ist unser Vorsitzender natürlich aber
sie sagen das doch mit einem Untertitel
es brauchte wirklich ein einzigen
Abgeordneten der gesagt hat ich klage
jetzt und seine Fraktion hat nicht
gesagt wir stoppen dich Klammer auf man
kann einen einzelnen Abgeordneten auch
nicht stoppen wenn er das will weil er
frei gewählte Abgeordneter ist also das
da werden die auch mit auf dem Bauch
gelandet aber es ist nicht so dass es
eine offizielle CDU Aktion gewesen wäre
sondern es war tatsächlich eine Heilmann
und seine zwei Freunde im büroaktion und
das ist schon interessant dass dieses
ich meine dieser Wirkungstreffer der
Union genau den haben eben nicht
Friedrich Merz und Co eingetütet sondern
nur er
ganz prinzipiell man sieht sie sind ja
auch in der klimaunion ne sie sind ja
der Bundesvorsitzende davon nicht
distanzieren und will auch gar nicht
nein sie sind Anliegen das Thema
sind Sie zufrieden mit diesem Gesetz
jetzt wie das kommt
ein Puzzle Stein in einem Gesamtkonzept
und damit bin ich überhaupt nicht
zufrieden und zwar sie wissen ja dass
ich Unternehmer bin weil die Zuschauer
das Wissen und deswegen gucke ich was
hinten rauskommt
und ehrlich gesagt in unserer Amtszeit
ist beim Klimaschutz nicht alles gut
gelaufen ich will jetzt hier nicht
irgendwie
Märchen erzählen also zum Thema hinten
rauskommen auch eher wenig
so wenig aber das ist zu viel Historiker
aber was ich sagen will ist auf der
Basis der Gesetze der großen Koalition
und im Förderkonzept der großen
Koalition hat es 2022 ein Rekord bei
Wärmepumpen gegeben hat sich ja bei den
Bürgern auch durch den Ukraine kriegen
und eine historischen niedrigen Einbau
von Ölheizung und Gasheizung und dann
hat die Ampel gesagt wir machen das
jetzt radikal anders mit dem Ergebnis
dass wir keine wärmepumpenrecorder haben
sondern ein Rekord an Öl und gashaltung
also genau das Gegenteil von dem woran
liegt es die wichtigste Frage ist doch
wer bezahlt die Mehrkosten weil es ist
am Anfang teurer den meisten
bestandshäusern wir reden nicht über
neue Häuser bestandshäuser auf eine
fossilfreie Energie umzustellen ist
teurer als die Ersatzinvestitionen in
der Gasheizung ich halte das für richtig
aber wir müssen klar verteilen was
zahlen der Steuerzahler was zahlt der
Eigentümer was zahlen die Miete kann man
natürlich lange darüber streiten wie man
es genau macht und das haben sie zuerst
mal zurückgesetzt und dann zu sagen aber
weil wir weniger fördern stellen wir
jetzt ein Verbot in Schaufenster und das
halte ich einfach als Transformation
Strategie für grundsätzlich falsch und
dann kommt noch hinzu dass diese
wärmeplanung nicht weiter gegangen ist
auch die muss man vormachen was heißt
wärmeplanung ich muss doch als als
Bürger der eine neue Heizung einfach
wissen kriege ich irgendwann Fernwärme
kriege ich irgendwann Nahwärme das muss
ich doch zuerst klären und dann kann ich
anfangen Vorschriften über ein
Heizungsbau zu machen außerdem ist die
Dämmung wichtiger als die Heizung also
lange Rede sind die Reihenfolge ist
sagen sie das gerade so also die Dämmung
ist wichtiger als die Heizung ja klar
weil die Energieeffizienz ist ja auch
eine Einsparung von Foss sie sagen dass
du nebenbei und so lässig ich habe mich
mit Christian Dörr genau dieses Thema
schon so gestritten hier weil mir dann
immer wieder erzählt wird nein nein nein
nein nein es geht auch alles so ich
glaube es ist die Summe aus allem genau
und ich kriege dann auch immer Post von
den entsprechenden Lobbyverbänden die
mich dann wieder beschimpfen und sagen
nein nein nein nein also das kann man
auch mit kleinen Heizungen machen kleine
Heizkörper und so theoretisch kann man
das auch aber wenn man mit Leuten
spricht die sich damit ein bisschen
auskennen dann sagen die das ist ein
bisschen wie im ersten Gang über die
Autobahn zu brettern du brauchst die
große flächige Heizung entweder auf dem
Boden oder
an der Wand weil du mit niedrigen
Temperaturen da rein gehst und dann
funktioniert das System auch Wärmepumpen
genaueren Vorlauftemperaturen
das ist sehr kompliziert ist es für
jedes Haus ist nicht dieselbe Lösung
richtig
aber sozusagen wenn ich jetzt an die
Ampel gehe dann ist einfach die ganze
Strategie aus meiner Sicht falsch
gewesen und das hochbedauerlich weil es
ja nur Verlierer gibt
deshalb ist nicht gut für unser
Gemeinwesen es ist katastrophal für den
Klimaschutz und das finde ich
bedauerlich aber wie das Opposition
haben die Aufgabe das zu markieren meine
Aufgabe
also das Thema ist in erkennbar wichtig
sie sagen ist katastrophal für den
Klimaschutz wenn das so läuft und dann
kommt vielleicht Schmerzen und sagt der
Hauptgegner in der Koalition sind die
Grünen
also ich habe das also ich finde die die
Begriff Hauptgegner die würde ich selber
so niemand nehmen weder bei den Grünen
noch bei den anderen Wettbewerber in der
Politik muss das Wettbewerb geben und
überhaupt Gegner und man merkt das ja
auch also da welchen Kriterium
eigentlich also ich will wenn ich schon
so habe würde ich aus meiner
unternehmerischen Perspektive sagen der
wichtigste ist der mit den größten
Marktanteilen wo ich am meisten Stimmen
kriegen kann
und dann ist es jetzt es wäre die SPD
oder SPD oder die AFD und im Osten die
AFD
ich würde aber auch die AFD nicht als
Hauptgegner bezeichnen ich finde das wir
müssen doch mit hoher Kompetenz sagen
wenn wir das machen würden würden wir es
besser machen so also die Regierung und
besser als die AFD das ist eine falsche
Aussage also es ist jedenfalls nicht
meiner Aussage und ich finde obwohl sie
noch mal kurz dran erinnern also bis
eben noch
also ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
hundertprozentig loyal zu unserem
Parteien fraktionsversichert das richtig
finde aber deswegen muss ich ja nicht
jeden Halbsatz in der sagt immer
derselben Meinung sein das ist ja das
auch albern ja falsch
Alexander wie finden sie das das was ist
das für eine Strategie ich meine man
regiert ja auch Henry bösen regiert mit
Daniel Günther regiert mich jetzt mal
unter Erwachsene das einer einer
Opposition sagt die Regierung ist der
Gegner und die Grünen die halt
da gerade ziemlich
meinungsführend sind in der Koalition
sind der Hauptgegner da bricht doch
nicht die Demokratie zusammen
Demokratie erzählt also das ist doch
also ich finde das ist so ein bisschen
der Objektiv ist es für die Union
schwierig weil sie einerseits sich von
den Grünen abgrenzen muss und
andererseits wenn man so sagt
anschlussfähig bleiben muss weil es wird
ja die nächste wenn Sie die Ampel
ablösen wollen jetzt in wahrscheinlich
wenn sie grün sein sonst ist wieder die
so zieht man eigentlich gerade nicht
mehr wollte so und deshalb ist es
wirklich objektiv schwierig und ich
glaube so zu lösen wie es Heilmann
gerade gesagt hat dass er eben nicht
gesagt hat ihr mit eurem Klima alles
misst sondern wie ihr das aufgesetzt
habt ist das falsch und wir hätten einen
anderen Vorschlag und dann hätte man
eine Debatte nicht viel Klimaschutz oder
wenig sondern hätte einen Debatte über
Wege zum Klimaschutz und dann wäre der
ganze Laden ist schon keins weiter was
anderes es geht ja auch um
Glaubwürdigkeit von Politiker an dem
Punkt die Leute sind noch nicht doof die
sehen doch mit wem die CDU die Union
überall regiert
nämlich mit den Grünen und dann stellt
man sich hin und sagt er das sind aber
also abituell kulturell das geht gar
nicht die wollen euch alles verwirrt
oder waren die Grünen in der Opposition
und haben gegen die große Koalition
geschimpft und haben auch in
Bundesländern mit der CDU zusammen
regiert also das ist einfach
unser Land aufgebaut
wenn man das so ganz offiziell erklärt
finde ich schon
vielleicht bin ich dazu Unsinn reden
so Verständnis
gesehen haben März sagt in der
regierungsche
sind sie da vom Stuhl gefallen
wir müssen die Bundesregierung irgendwie
stärker stellen und Hauptgegner in der
Bundesregierung sind die Grünen sagt der
CDU vorsitzender ist das etwas was sie
erschüttert haben sie jetzt Angst haben
ja
ich glaube generell dass man mit
Gegnerschaft nicht super konstruktiv
umgehen kann also vielleicht komme ich
aus dem Team Wissenschaft und bin
deshalb eh mehr auf Inhalte gepolt als
auf politische Streitigkeiten
deshalb würde ich glaube ich generell
mit diesem Gegner etwas vorsichtig
umgehen
also niemand ist meiner Meinung ich sehe
ich habe aber was Team Schäuble der hat
dazu im Tagesspiegel wie ich finde genau
die richtige Wortwahl getroffen
natürlich ist die Grünen unser
politischer Gegner wir sind im
Wettbewerb aber sie sind nicht unsere
Feinde und du hatte ausgedrückt aber wir
sollten doch anfangen
ja Wettbewerber ist doch dann viel
konstruktiver interessanter als Gegner
ist ja auch meine Vokabeln aber wenn man
gar nicht dass die Grünen das so schlimm
finden der Gegner von Friedrich Merz zu
sein ich glaube das halten die auch aus
können die trotzdem noch schlafen ich
glaube es ist fast eine Notwendigkeit
wenn man weiter bei den Grünen
erfolgreich sein ich will mal was
anderes weil heute hier ein sehr
erfolgreicher Unternehmer sitzt
die Frage der Anreize
Leute sozusagen mit Anreizen dazu zu
bringen Dinge freiwillig zu machen so
sehr interessant wenn man auch in einem
Land wie Sachsen Anhalt zum Beispiel wo
übrigens der CDU Ministerpräsident
Rainer Haseloff unfassbar viele
Windräder aufgestellt hat sehr
erfolgreich in den letzten Jahren und
ganz
signifikant Strom liefert zum Beispiel
nach Baden-Württemberg ja deswegen Intel
bekommen und deswegen Intel bekommt
auch mal wenn man immer so über
Bürokratie schimpft und Verwaltung ich
glaube die haben dann echt guten Job
gemacht den Magdeburg bei der Frage wie
locken wir die hierher aber 10
Milliarden sind auch nicht ohne hätten
sie das als Unternehmer finden Sie das
gut dass die 10 Milliarden kriegen
also wenn sie mich so fragen nein ich
hätte die Entscheidung trotzdem
getroffen ja also aber die ist natürlich
grenzwertig das ist ja so
Subventionen sind grundsätzlich falsch
und man muss Ausnahmen machen und
nachdem in diesem Bereich sowieso so
viele Subventionen ist war auch aus
Deutschland jetzt eindeutig mal dran und
insofern hätte ich es auch so
entschieden aber ist nicht ganz
unproblematisch dieser ganze
subventionsfeldlauf ist nicht richtig
den ist ja Zwischenstand
zum Beispiel Amerikaner machen das ja
auch die Chinesen machen auch
Verständnis für die deutschen
Unternehmen die sagen na dann gehen wir
mal dahin also die die machen das auch
viel unbürokratischer und ähm ja auch
sehr erfolgreich und das sollten also
unser ganzer europäische und auch unter
Deutsch habe ich sehr viel
bürokratischer und glaube ich nicht
erfolgreicher